it's not even open yet but those with no
other options wait at this clinic in
central athens volunteers from a group
called doctors of the world run it for
free it's where many greets get what
they can no longer pay for check-ups and
medicine I'm a building contractor but
because of the crisis I've had such
little work I haven't been able to pay
my health insurance for four years so
they don't pay for my heart pills the
pills are vital for stelios prawn
elitist and the clinic his last hope he
is just one of an estimated third of the
Greek population which is unable to pay
for health insurance dentist nikki says
Kanakis comes regularly to the clinic to
offer his skills for free he says he
understands the difficulties his
patients face and wants to help is not
only the numbers is the problems they
have they become more complex problems
it's not just someone who is looking for
a medicine someone who's struggling to
survive because for some kind of
patients like diabetic patients to find
the instrument that he needs it's a
fight for life every day kanak has paid
special attention to his younger
patients he knows that if they don't get
proper treatment now they could face
serious complications later that would
be bad for them and also for the Greek
healthcare system it was a system that
even before he doesn't work didn't work
we spend a lot of money by giving the
people around but we didn't create all
the necessary that we needed now we
crisis we realize that the situation was
worst than one what we thought that we
have and is not a social net that will
help people survive so volunteers give
their time to run this clinic it's
funded by donations from abroad from
within the European Union people are
being given the minimum to keep
themselves afloat stelios prana etos is
grateful for his pills
he's not ashamed to be dependent on help
but he hopes that things will change
after the elections wish I was in a
visual on A&E yawning and I give me you
mean but I think it will be difficult
and if things do change it will
certainly not happen quickly but I hope
that things will improve for my
daughter's generation moment is when
you're in yet the deity Gautam oh he's
got what he needs but for the clinic
staff it's going to be another long day
the queue by the door does not seem to
have become any shorter